hey Maddie hi front so I'm pretty
excited because there are so many
amazing video games coming out in the
next couple of months too many for me to
even name but one of which is that I'm
extremely excited about is Super Mario
maker which if you guys have been hiding
under a rock or hiding under it
somewhere I don't where the heck you're
hiding this game is so much fun I had a
chance to play it I actually have a
video I'll put a link in the description
if you guys want to go there and vote
for my level you are so itchy babe so I
made a level I'm up against a couple
other YouTube creators so if you guys go
there click like leave me a nice comment
we've got the game and we've got the
30th anniversary this is the classic
color Mario it comes in two colors that
I come here check this out hun G hear
that sound you sure that song do you
know what that sound is that's the sound
of fun look at you Oh aren't you so
inquisitive could get a kiss we don't we
don't encourage kisses I don't like
other people's dogs licking me all over
the face I don't want my dog to with me
all over the face or lick strangers all
over the place look at this baby are you
pumped up god this is such a beautiful
amiracle it's heavy feel like the same
way as a Bowser one my everyone haven't
seen you in a while no just kidding they
see you every single day because I post
something else with my dog
what do you think mind okay we're not
gonna eat this because I want this what
do we have in here do you care you know
like when I play video games because I'm
you know attention for you actually he
does like when I play video games
because all I do is mess with him all
day long no no I gotta cut this open I
gotta cut this open hang on bud okay all
right let's transfer our attention over
here leave it we were having a debate
yesterday on what color we thought the
case was gonna be it's actually red look
at that I thought I was gonna be blue
what was it gonna be yellow
oh the booklet so it comes with a super
cute little booklet to help you with
some inspiration on creating levels yeah
isn't it great yeah look it's your
favorite like what do you think what are
you thinking about this hey come here
you can get all my here play with that
for just a hot minute just a hot minute
okay so here's the booklet it's
everything that you ever hoped dreamed
for I'm pretty excited because I'm
thinking about doing a few live streams
of creating some level li1 I wanted to
be some sort of interaction and usually
I'm just playing Call of Duty with
Minecraft would you guys will actually
let go be like we'll actually get to
play the levels that I've created so let
me know what you guys think about live
streaming let me don't you think about
like dog if you say one main thing you
can say anything mean that you want
about me but don't be mean to Maddie um
make sure you guys following on
Instagram because he's cute no joking
but Mario maker let me know also what
video games you're looking forward to
there's so many coming out I'm just
losing my mind
there's not enough time to play them all
if they're Maddie especially not because
you got mad you cannot have that this is
not for pups I'll see you guys later
I'm gonna go play this game now hi
Oh Maddie you're so cute you're so fun
toss technique you it is okay oh wait
there he's 300 so that's my best if you
guys can beat that let me